a long time we have known that those who
have died from coronavirus a significant
proportion have had underlying health
conditions and for the first time these
figures have been published showing a
breakdown of the different conditions
and I just want to talk you through the
highest risk groups and so it's found
that 26% of those who've died with an
underlying health condition have also
had diabetes so type 1 and to 18% have
had dementia we know that a high
proportion of elderly people have died
of coronavirus and 15% have had chronic
pulmonary disease so those are the
breakdown and it does give us an insight
for the very first time the types of
groups that are at risk of coronavirus
it's also worth mentioning from the
figures today that yesterday the highest
number of tests carried out from the
start of the corona virus pandemic were
carried out in this country a hundred
and twenty-six thousand just over one
hundred and twenty-six thousand tests
and those are tests that are carried out
at testing facilities but also tests
that have been posted out to people who
perhaps need them they might not have
carried out those tests yet but they're
certainly on route in the post and we've
also had another figure today that's
worth pointing out and that is a figure
from the office for national statistics
and they found in a two-week period from
the end of April to May a hundred and
forty thousand people in England were
living with coronavirus and the whole
point of getting that figure is to try
and repeat it on a regular basis so they
can really crack down on that our number
and find out the spread of the virus
throughout the country and also another
development in medical terms the
antibody tests that are now we believe
100% effective that are going to be
rolled out across the UK yes sir Boris
Johnson has previously said that certain
antibody tests could be a real
game-changer and these ones have been
developed in a Swiss lab and they've
then been checked over at Porton down in
Wiltshire and basically they've found
that they are 100% reliable they cannot
be tested at home they have to be
carried out in a clinical environment
with healthcare workers taking a sample
of blood which will then be sent off to
a laboratory and you'll get the results
later on but the issues are of course
given that we are in
a worldwide global pandemic testing
hundreds of thousands of people every
single week at an NHS facility would be
very very difficult so it's my
understanding these first off will be
given to NHS workers and patients
currently in hospitals so it's easier
for them to do but certainly the
reliability looks very very positive
indeed we don't yet know whether if
you've had coronavirus you won't get it
again
but certainly this will point out
whether people have antibodies and then
they can get an idea whether they can
return to work whether they're less
likely of contracting it again but it's
certainly a very positive step and it
could be very crucial in terms of really
stopping the spread of the virus across
the country